we used to look up in the sky and wonder
that I play
I just look down and worry about our
place in and dirt go for main engine
start
t-minus 10 we must confront the reality
that nothing in our solar system can
help us 9 I've got kids professor how
long whatever young hey I'm asking you
to trust me
7 you have to talk to me in there 6 need
to fix this before I know 5 main engines
start
could you told her you're about to save
the world No
three one thing comes really clear too
as that you wanna make sure your
children feel safe one
I'm coming back
I love you forever potentially habitable
worlds right within our reach and save
us from extinction here we go
you can't just think about your family
now you have to think bigger than that
I'm thinking about my family and me two
other families
maybe we've spent too long trying to
figure all this out with theory
is the one thing that transcends time
and space
do not go gentle into that good night
days should burn and rave at close of
day
rage rage against the dying
yes you are
we'll find a way we always have
you